so liebe leute es ist mal zeit für eine
ansage es gibt eine minderheit die meint
dass es ok wäre hier öfter mal unter dem
videos kritik an dem video titeln zu
äußern auch wenn die mehrheit da ganz
anderer meinung ist warum trollen hier
unter den videos und nur darum geht es
überflüssig und sinnlos ist und ich mich
über konstruktive kritik wirklich feuer
das jetzt in klicks um science-fiction
herzlich willkommen erst mal ein riesen
dank an alle die den kanal unterstützen
in den letzten wochen ist er wirklich
komplett durch die decke gegangen und
hat alle rekorde gebrochen bis zu
dreieinhalb millionen views im monat das
ist absolut der hammer und was für einen
bildungs für einen wissenschafts kanal
unglaublich ja gestern gab es kritik an
dem video titel ich kann ihnen noch
auswendig drohende asteroiden einschläge
das wird passieren und an diesem titel
gab es kritik ehrlich gesagt dafür gibt
es überhaupt keinen grund warum ganz
einfach es drohen asteroiden anschläge
und sie passieren sie 2013 chelyabinsk
und zweitens im video habe ich eine
studie erläutert die die konsequenzen
aufzeigt wenn ein solcher astrid ins
meer stürzt was ist also an dem titel
falsch ich kann es genau sagen nichts
mehr stimmt zu 100 prozent mit dem
inhalt überein
da gibt es andere titel über die man
diskutieren könnte was nicht heißt dass
sie falsch sind aber man könnte über sie
diskutieren bei diesem titel nicht
einfach nicht da scheint es aber leute
in alarmstimmung zu geben die bei jedem
krassen titel wie ein pawlowscher und
reagieren und unbedingt darunter
kommentieren müssen
das ist aber mal einfach nicht okay die
kommentar übrig gehört zum video und ich
lasse dort kommentare zu auch kritisch
konstruktive die den inhalt voranbringen
alles andere gehört da nicht hin und ich
werde solche kommentare wie gesagt es
geht um trollen in zukunft noch
konsequenter löschen und in krassen
fällen auch die leute die die funktionen
zum trollen nutzen
das ist einfach nicht okay und ja wen
die titel stören und wer nicht
verstanden hat warum sie so sind ja ihr
könnt den kanal gerne die abonnieren
das ist vielleicht für alle besser wir
machen hier nämlich krasse video titel
wie es auch in der kanal beschreibung
schon länger steht um auch leute die
sich nicht so für wissenschaft
interessieren
dazu zu bewegen die videos zu schauen
und der erfolg
gibt mir recht so viele schreiben mir
unter den videos wegen dir habe ich
leistungskurs matte gewählt oder ich bin
in physik von vier auf eins gekommen
oder letztlich von einem mädchen wegen
dir studiere ich physik bäm
das ist der schönste lohn den ein kanal
bekommen kann und kommentare wie das ist
ja wie in der bild -zeitung bestätigen
dann nur meine bemühungen und sind ein
großes lob denn was viele vielleicht
nicht wissen die inhalte in der bild
sind zu einem erheblichen teil müll aber
für die überschriften bereiten sie viele
journalisten und journalistinnen die
bild zeitung hat nämlich die
suchmaschinenoptimierte schlagzeile in
den 50er jahren erfunden als sie die
leute die an den pfosten vorbeiging
catchen muss natürlich muss der titel
auch zum video passen und das video darf
danach nicht enttäuschen und wenn es da
kritik gibt und das wissen alle setze
ich sie auch immer sofort um aber wenn
der titel eins zu eins den inhalt wieder
gibt dann läuft jede kritik in diese
richtung ins leere vielleicht entspannt
sich jetzt mal der ein oder andere oder
die eine oder andere und denkt mal
darüber nach ansonsten hier jetzt ein
video was youtube für jeden von euch
individuell ausgesucht hat also
unbedingt draufklicken ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran